(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Але якщо ні, то буде запис.
Але так, завтра ми будемо розглядати базу даних,
ми будемо MongoDB розглядати, вона не реляційна база
даних, але загалом, як для розробки сайту будь
-якого, вона дуже підійде, і там десь близько
15 рядків коду це додавання бази даних і
далі просто його використання.
А що, до речі, саме в MongoDB?
Вона безкоштовна, просто це єдиний плюс в нашому
випадку, що проблема в тому, що, наприклад, MSSQL
від Microsoft комерційна, тобто його знайти безкоштовно немає,
в MySQL вони, частіше за все, дуже прив
'язані до PHP йдуть, тобто знайти безкоштовно можна,
але вони не дають прямого доступу, типу воно
прив'язане лише в їхніх сервісах, і фактично
MongoDB вони пропонують пожиттєвий безкоштовний простенький сервер до
500 МБ пам'яті, дуже такий маленький для
реальної розробки, воно, звісно, не підійде з користувачами,
але для ось таких проєктів, коли потрібно щось
дуже базове зробити, це цілком гарний варіант.
І тому також додатковий варіант, що MongoDB використовують
дуже часто, коли ви хочете зробити швидкий прототип,
тому що в MongoDB можна закидати все, що
завгодно, він там фактично не має якоїсь структури,
тому туди можна закидувати будь-які об'єкти
і не перейматися за структуру таблиць, наприклад, тому
що таблиць як таких там немає взагалі.
Добре, цікаво буде.
Поглянемо, як вийде, загалом я думаю, що мало
б вийти, під'єднатися з тих, тому що
одразу можна буде використовувати базу даних, наприклад, для
кожного, з вашою командою створив одну базу даних
і кожен під'єднався і може її використовувати
легко.
Будемо розглядати більше завтра на заняття.
У нас завтра, до речі, на 9.30,
якщо я не помиляюсь.
Так, у нас лекційного заняття немає, тому на
9.30. Я сподіваюся, що завтра буде більше
ваших колег позаминулої п'ятниці.
Тому будемо дивитися.
Добре.
Думаю, що люди до того часу прокинуться.
Добре, тоді зупиняю запис.